Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schöne guten Morgen Richard guten Morgen
Markus wo erreiche ich dich
immer am gleichen Ort wenn ich mit dir
nicht auf einer Bühne stehe ja oder in
Amsterdam ja auf Ziegelsteine gucke wie
war's gut
ich habe ganz ganz viel gelernt über
Hörakustik
hörakustiken ist mega spannendes Feld ne
ist tatsächlich viel spannender als man
sich so auf dem ersten Blick denkt also
ich finde das wichtigste glaube ich was
ich gelernt habe so am Rande das war so
eine kleine Fachfrage die ich hatte das
ist äh in meiner Beziehung wird mir sehr
oft nachgesagt ich wäre schwerhörig und
ich teile dieses ich
vielen anderen Männern die auch nicht
schwerhörig sind ja was wird immer
wieder gesagt sollte man Ohren
untersuchen lassen und so weiter und ich
habe jetzt den Fachbegriff dafür gehört
wie das heißt wenn man nicht gut genug
zuhört und den Verdacht erregt
schwerhörig zu sein und das ist
harthörig harthörig ja natürlich sind
Menschen die keinen Hörschaden haben
aber trotzdem nicht zuhören okay genau
aber haartürig ist er klingt eher so
nach hartnäckiger Verweigerung ja genau
das ist natürlich gar nicht so gemeint
das ist das Thema das ist das ist nur
dass ich nicht immer denken und zuhören
Gleichzeitigkeit herrlich es gibt die
Moment eine Debatte und es gibt auch ein
Gefühl nämlich das Gefühl dass dieses
Land irgendwie nicht mehr so richtig auf
dem Weg nach oben sondern bestenfalls
irgendwie so geradeaus unterwegs ist und
tendenziell eigentlich nach unten und
richtige kulturpe sie müssten sagen
Deutschland ist verloren mit Deutschland
geht's endgültig bergab es gibt eine
Studie dazu sehr interessant kann dieser
Tage in keinem anderen Industrieland
Arbeiten Erwerbstätige mittlerweile so
wenig wie in Deutschland
die Erosion des Fleisches ist ja wie wie
man sagen könnte pass auf im Laufe eines
Jahres fallen hierzulande nur noch 1.3
50 ungefähr Arbeitsstunden an im Schnitt
in der EU sind
1566 also fast 70 mehr in Japan 1.600
also 100 mehr in Amerika sogar fast
10800 also die die
amerikanische Arbeitsverhältnisse kennt
kann man sich das vorstellen Menschen
die zwei drei Jobs gleichzeitig haben
die Arbeiten richtig aber der Punkt ist
nirgendwo
Industrieländern ja wird so wenig
gearbeitet wie in Deutschland und das
passt eigentlich für ein Gerüchten so
und jetzt warte mal meine Kontakten ich
habe noch einmal zahlen du erinnerst
dich wir haben auch kurz darüber
gesprochen es gab kürzliche Untersuchung
über 80% der Deutschen sagen wir wollen
unbedingt die vier Tage Woche richtig ja
und aber natürlich gerne bei vollen
Bezügen das heißt einfach ein bisschen
mehr frei und ich als jemand der
irgendwann mal so in dieses Land
gekommen ist ja das immer so dieses
Image hatte die fleißigen hart arbeiten
in deutschen ja Tag und Nacht und wenn
es irgendwo richtig läuft dann bei den
Deutschen mich ich weiß gar nicht ob du
das nachvollziehen kannst aber mich als
als kleinen Arbeitsmigranten erschüttert
also ich versuche deine Erschütterung zu
reduzieren danke mit dem Satz Quantität
ist nicht gleich Qualität
also der der große wilfredo Pareto
Soziologe Anfang des Jahrhunderts hat ja
ganz viele Prinzipien aufgestellt eines
heißt sogar Pareto Prinzip und da heißt
das dass 80% einer Leistung in 20% der
dafür aufgewendeten Zeit vollbracht wird
und ich glaube das ist ein sehr vielen
Arbeitsplätzen genau das gleiche es
kommt nicht auf die Summe der
Arbeitsstunden und es kommt darauf an
was am Ende dabei rauskommt Helmut Kohl
erstmal ist es klar genau was unten
rauskommt immer zu sagen pflege erstmal
ist es so dass wie viele gearbeitet wird
in einem Land ja auch abhängig ist von
gerade der Technisierung richtig na das
ist ja in Land in dem wahnsinnig viel
Handarbeit gemacht werden muss auch mehr
gearbeitet werden als da wo Maschinen im
Einsatz sind so und das gleiche geht
natürlich auch für Automatisierung und
vieles andere mehr das heißt allein an
den Arbeitsstunden kann man die
Produktivität eines Volkes überhaupt
nicht abmessen das wäre schon mal
ziemlich wichtiger Konter zweitens
müsste man mal genau untersuchen also du
gehst in eine italienische Verwaltung in
eine schwedische und in eine deutsche
zum Beispiel und dann misst du mal die
netto-arbeitszeit
weil wir müssen ja nur bruttoarbeitszeit
also du arbeitest da 37 Stunden oder
sowas du arbeitest ja keine 37 Stunden
du bist da du bist jetzt erstmal da ne
und dann sagst du hallo und je nachdem
wie viel Kollegen hast gehst du in 12
oder 14 Büros und sagst hallo und dann
bist du ja gerade von der Reise
zurückgekommen und dann zeigst du noch
Urlaubsfotos sondern wirst du das
gefragt und die Kaffeepause dauert auch
länger und so Mittagessen
also das ist in jedem Büro mehr oder
weniger so sehr wenigen Ausnahmen
abgesehen das heißt die soziale
Arbeitszeit hat nichts mit der forme ein
arbeitseinschonenden
mal besonders gesprächigen Ländern ja
zu arbeiten seit relativ kleiner ist
relativ kleiner ist als die
bruttoarbeitszeit und deswegen die
Arbeitsstunden messen gar nicht zusammen
Gespräche Geländer was ist das naja
würdest du sagen dass jedes Land genau
gleichgesprächig ist also jetzt wenn du
Finnland mit Palermo vergleichst würde
ich sagen ist Palermo eher der Gespräche
Teil ja vermute ich auch ja den Grönland
gewesen richtig richtig ist der
Grönländer der Gründer der redet das ist
interessant wenn es dich interessiert
erzähle ich dir das ist wirklich
interessant also wenn wenn ein
grönländischer Jäger zu dir in das
Häuschen kommt in dem Du gerade bist
dann kommen den aller Regel um mich zu
besuchen weil sie sich freundlich zu
sehen und das zweite ist er kommt um
Kaffee zu trinken ja die trinken diesen
ganz starken diesen in den Kopf ja
Nescafé ist das Maß aller Dinge so und
dann sitzt er da und du denkst okay
jetzt reden wir ein bisschen und dann
wird er da und dann sitzt da weiter so
was passiert eigentlich nichts das ist
aber nur mir peinlich ihm nicht die
sitzen lernt reden ganz wenig das ist
das ist irgendwie schön aber für ein
Menschen sondern mit meinem Beruf
irritieren kann
Intimität und Intensität entstehen durch
gemeinsames Schweigen richtig
du das ist ja auch in vielen Männer hast
Freundschaften so ja dass man sich nicht
jetzt komplett aus und leer plaudert
sondern das ist auch einfach schön ist
zusammen zu wandern und stundenlang
gemeinsam über das gleiche zu schweigen
das stimmt das stimmt ja machst du hier
ich mache das gerne traut man mir nicht
zu weil
beide nicht so ein Trappisten Image
ist aber so tatsächlich ja also ich bin
nur anonymer Schweiger ne wenn man mich
nicht beobachtet schweige ich sehr gut
ich ich bist du durch mit deinem
Argument ich hätte jetzt ein topconter
für dich hast du was bist du bereit bist
du ich
folgendes also alles was du sagst alles
richtig ja also man kann sozusagen mit
Produktivität mit höherer Produktivität
ja vieles wegmachen aber jetzt kommt's
auf der anderen Seite bröckels auch also
es gibt auch sozusagen neben der Erosion
des Fleisches auch ein Erosion des
Könnens ja wie wie Thomas Meyer zum
Beispiel ist ein Ökonomen sagt und sagt
da gibt es ein riesiges Problem weil
gleichzeitig bröckelts am anderen Ende
bei der Ausbildung Lesen Rechnen
Schreiben ja und der zieht Parallelen
zum Italien der 80er Jahre wo genau das
eine eine riesige Wirtschaftskrise
eingeleitet hat in einen
wirtschaftlichen Abstieg eingeleitet hat
ne dass das Bildungsniveau immer weiter
gesunken ist das heißt wir kommen
schlicht und ergreifend nicht mehr mit
bei dem was da gefragt ist und auch dazu
gerade die jüngst wieder haben wir ja
neulich drüber gesprochen diese Studie
das ist jetzt auch die Mädchen erwischt
ich meine die Mädchen waren nie unsere
Sorgenkinder sondern es waren eher die
Jungs die man so vom Computer vermutet
hat und so weiter und die dann irgendwie
vor sich hindaddeln und und und eben
nicht Hausaufgaben machen und lernen die
Mädchen waren nie die Sorgenkinder aber
jetzt sind plötzlich auch die Mädchen
die Sorgenkinder die speziell in allen
MINT-Fächern mat und so weiter wirklich
sie signifikant zurückfallen und das
zusammen sagt er ist hochexplosiv und
gefährlich ja also ich finde das sehr zu
betrauern wenn es stimmen sollte dass
man heute viel weniger schreiben kann
als früher und dass das dann irgendwann
durch Chichi PT komplett ersetzt wird
weil der Reichtum man innerer Welt
abnimmt wenn man seine Schreibfähigkeit
eine der wenigen Dinge die Menschen von
Tieren unterscheidet wenn man die
verliert also der der sprachliche
Ausdruck der schriftliche sprachliche
Ausdruck ist eine unglaubliche
Bereicherung der eigenen inneren Welt ob
er für den Arbeitsmarkt die große
Katastrophe ist wird sich herausstellen
weil man sich fragen muss wie viele
Berufe gibt es in denen man toll
schreiben können muss
und wie viele Berufe gibt es wo man das
was da jetzt geschrieben wird einfach
auch wunderbar ersetzen könnte eben
durch Chichi PT und anderes zum Beispiel
diese ganzen Texte die in Verwaltung
geschrieben wird
halbkünstliche Intelligenz ne also es
kommt nicht aufs eigene Denken drauf an
man muss Intelligenz aufwenden aber in
regelbasierten Bahnen in denen man sich
keine individuellen Eskapaden leisten
darf sondern genau Gegenteil ne du
willst damit nicht sagen dass auf
unseren Ämtern halbintelligenz unterwegs
ist um das noch mal ganz deutlich zu
sagen nicht dass das wieder ein falschen
Zungenschlag kriegt nicht wie sagen dass
unser Ämtern die Anforderungen genau
und dass wir viele Menschen die dort
arbeiten auch genau darunter leiden und
da vorne viel mehr von ihrer Intelligenz
Gebrauch machen würden aber das eben
sehr viel Bürokratie diese Intelligenz
ja auch gar nicht zulässt und nicht
einfach antworten und deswegen haben wir
es damit halt günstiger ins Intelligenz
auch schön
deutsche Beamtentum quasi halb
künstliche Intelligenz könnte man jetzt
verkürzt daraus machen nicht das gesamte
Beamtentum nicht der Polizist ja aber
auch nicht der General ja auch nicht
jeder Lehrer ja aber es gibt natürlich
eine große Anzahl von Tätigkeiten die
tatsächlich den Anforderungen halb
künstlicher Intelligenz entsprechen
sorry hat und jetzt noch mal das Thema
also was auch interessant ist nach der
Wiedervereinigung ne nach den 90er
Jahren 1990er Jahren
in den 1990er Jahren hat hat der
durchschnittliche deutsche Arbeitnehmer
noch deutlich mehr als diese 1550
Stunden gearbeitet die ich eben zitiert
habe seitdem ist die Arbeitszeit
kontinuierlich zurückgegangen und du
sagst man kann davon vieles mit
Produktivität wett machen und so weiter
sagt nichts über die Qualität der Arbeit
aus und so weiter ich will auch was
anderes hinaus Richard ich glaube oder
würdest Du der These zustimmen ähm
Stichwort den Industrialisierung
Deutschlands dieser langsame nieder
wegen dieser langsame Abstieg den viele
im Moment wahrnehmend an vielen Stellen
und alle weisen immer darauf hin mit dem
man so redet naja das ist jetzt nichts
was so über Nacht passiert das geht ganz
langsam das geht so langsam immer weiter
runter zum Beispiel ist so so Indikator
wie die Patentanmeldungen ja du hast in
Deutschland dann den Rückgang der
Patentanmeldungen um 6,5% ungefähr
während du zu gleichen Zeit in China
einen Zuwachs von
23,5% hast
dazu passen dann auch so Sachen wie
capital ich glaube so heißen die ist der
größte Batteriehersteller der Welt
Chinesen natürlich die haben kürzlich
angekündigt dass sie jetzt eine Batterie
auf den Markt bringen werden die einfach
das Doppelte dessen kann was die im
Moment besten Batterien zu leisten in
der Lage sind und es ist natürlich eine
gute Nachricht mit Blick auf
Elektromobilität und überhaupt auf die
Elektrifizierung der Welt aber es ist
eine schlechte Nachricht gleichzeitig
wenn man Zug zusammen und sagt man warum
kommt dieser Innovationssprung von den
Chinesen warum nicht verloren bekannte
Erklärung dafür die ist schon ein paar
Jahre alt und jetzt ihre Gültigkeit
nicht verloren das ist wenn du auf einem
Sektor wahnsinnig erfolgreich bist die
Deutschen mit ihrer Ingenieurskunst dann
kann das leicht passieren dass du
künftige Entwicklungen die nicht direkt
was damit zu tun haben nur indirekt
damit zu tun haben die also nicht eine
Perfektionierung der Ingenieurskunst
darstellen dass du die verschläfst und
das ist eine interessante Geschichte ich
war vor einigen Jahren in Argentinien
und habe mir damals die Frage gestellt
warum ist Argentinien heute ein armes
Land weil wenn man durch Buenos Aires
geht dann sieht man das war mal ein sehr
sehr sehr reiches Land und tatsächlich
in den 20er Jahren gehörte Argentinien
zu den fünf reichsten Ländern der Welt
überlegt und so sehen da auch die Häuser
aus ne man denkt also die haben ja Paris
locker in den Schatten gestellt die
haben Häuser wie in Paris gebaut in der
Höhe von New York 20 stückige 25
stückige Stück Paläste dahin gebaut ganz
besonders
Wohlstand aber dieser Wohlstand der
wurde damals ermöglicht durch die
Fleischwirtschaft
und die Fleischwirtschaft ist natürlich
nicht das wovon heute noch irgendein
Land reich werden könnte was man also
dringend in exakt derselben Zeit als man
die Paläste gebaut hat hätte machen
müssen wäre die zweite industrielle
Revolution zu verziehen die konnte man
aber nicht vollziehen weil man in der
ersten industriellen Revolution ja also
jetzt hier Produktion von Stahl und so
weiter ja auch keine ernste lebende
Rolle spielte konnte man in der zweiten
also Herstellung von Autos und von von
Konsumgütern durch hochindustrielle
Fertigung auch gar nicht richtig
aufsatteln also hat mal gesagt wieso
hier mit Fleisch das klappt doch genau
man hat also die Kuh so lange gemolken
bis sie tot war ja und das passiert sehr
sehr leicht und in Deutschland ist das
gleiche passiert passiert
weil jeder jetzt an bestimmte Dinge in
die gleich denkt und die digitale
Revolution verschlafen ist immer so ein
ist eigentlich gar kein schönes Wort ja
verschlafen klingt so als hätte man es
überhaupt nicht mitgekriegt oder so nein
man hat sich auf das besonnen wo
Deutschland wahnsinnig stark ist und hat
sehr lange moderne amerikanische
Software ja in alte mit alt meine ich
nicht böse sondern sozusagen seit
längerer Zeit existierende deutsche
Technik eingebaut und wir haben unsere
Autos lange Zeit einfach nur damit
verbessert und waren stolz darauf auf
unsere ingenieurtechnikleistungen das
dann eine disruption passiert bis wir
die nächst beim Automobil ja noch viel
brutaler kriegen wenn wir nach China
unsere Autos nicht mehr verkaufen können
dass das was uns so lange ernährt hat
zum Beispiel das Auto Deutschland macht
ja auch noch ganz viele andere Sachen
großartige Ingenieurskunst dass das
plötzlich nicht mehr nachgefragt wird
dieser Fall ist da nicht vorgesehen
und das ist in Deutschland nun de facto
passiert obwohl wir ja was die
Digitalisierung anbelangt in der
Grundlagenforschung er von Anfang an zu
den besten und fortgeschrittensten
Ländern der Erde gehört so und das führt
uns Richard direkt zu einer ganz großen
Frage und was das neulich so ein paar so
erwähnt sagt es ist eines meiner
Lieblingsbücher mit dem habe ich mich
gerade noch mal beschäftigt nämlich
dieses ganz bekannte Buch glaub schon 10
Jahre alt warum Nationen scheitern ja ja
warum warum scheitern Nationen plötzlich
wenn es doch irgendwie die ganze Weile
gut geht es gibt ein paar faszinierende
Dinge die man da in dem Zusammenhang
auch noch mal so erwähnen kann du kennst
ihn halt Ferguson ich lese immer
wahnsinnig gerne Bücher und Texte von
allen Fersen
Provokateur der der sich darüber neulich
auch Gedanken gemacht hat und und sagte
stehen die jetzt wirklich am Ende von
500 Jahren sozusagen westlicher
Vorherrschaft der Stichwort später
römische dekadens so mal einen ber
FDP-Vorsitzenden zu zitieren ich kann
mich sehr gut daran erinnern als der
berühmte FDP-Vorsitzende das gesagt hat
ich war zu dem Thema sogar in einer
Talkshow ja es ist auch elf Jahre her
ist elf Jahre her ja so und ich höre
interessanterweise diesen Satz in
letzter Zeit wieder häufiger geht dir
das auch so dieses Gefühl wir sind wir
sind wir wir wollen nicht mehr so
richtig wir wollen uns auch nicht mehr
so richtig anstrengen und der Anfang vom
Ende wird kommen und was wird aus
unseren Kindern werden und wir steigen
der Westen insgesamt aber vor allen
Dingen auch Deutschland steigt ab die
Angst vor Wohlstandsverlust und nein
Ferguson sagt das glaubt er nicht er
sagt ich glaube nicht dass ich der ganze
Westen die USA und auch Deutschland in
so einem unaufhaltsame Niedergang
befindet aber gehört eben auch nicht zu
den Optimisten die schönes Momo so
Winston Churchill mäßig der Meinung sind
die USA die Amerikaner werden am Ende
schon das Richtige tun wenn sie erst
einmal alle anderen Möglichkeiten
erschöpft und ausprobiert haben und
irgendwann werden sie auf den rechten
Weg zurückfinden aber der weiß doch was
total interessant ist hin der sagt zum
Beispiel und da siehst du das nichts in
Stein gemeißelt ist um 1500 herum war
der Durchschnitts Chinese reiche als der
durchschnittliche nordamerikanische so
und Ende der 70er des vorigen
Jahrhunderts ja 70er Jahre war der
durchschnittliche Amerikaner im 15
Jahrhundert war ein indigener meint er
16 ist mein 16 Jahrhundert der sagte
die aus England und Frankreich rüber kam
genau so aber auch zum Beispiel das
interessant Ende der 70er waren dann
schon der die die Amerikaner 20 mal
reicher als die Chinesen die haben die
abgehängt die waren größer ein physisch
die Wand gesünder die lebten länger die
waren mächtiger geworden ja diese arme
Leute die da irgendwann mal rüber sind
in diese neue Welt und haben dann Anfang
des 20 Jahrhunderts haben die im Grunde
die halbe Welt
kontrolliert 58 Prozent der Landfläche
und Bevölkerungen und 74% der
Weltwirtschaft das heißt das ist eine
gigantische Erfolgsgeschichte ja und die
Frage ist könnte das jetzt an einem
Punkt kommen an dem das endet also noch
mal warum scheitern Nationen genau und
jetzt ist es ja so dass die die beiden
bevor wir uns mit Fergusons Argumenten
beschäftigen
diese beiden Autoren die das Buch
geschrieben haben James Robinson und
daran assimuglu ich kenne vor allen
Dingen daran dass hier muglu ganz gut
das ist der bedeutendste
Arbeitsmarktforscher der USA und wer ein
Buch überarbeitet schreibt der muss sich
ausführlich mit seinen Studien
auseinandersetzen und er ist dann
absolutes Schwergewicht dieser Zunft und
davon hat der Mann auch richtig Angst
deswegen kennst du den so gut ja
was er schreibt ist immer nie begegnet
wird es aber gerne tun und der sehr viel
kluge Studien gemacht über
roboterisierung und wie sich
Arbeitsmärkte entwickeln und so weiter
also da ist absoluter Kenner der Materie
und er hat sich dann eben mit James
Robinson den er offensichtlich auch
schon aufgesetzt aus seiner Studienzeit
kannte zusammengetan und hat ihm
versucht die Frage zu lösen gibt es
eigentlich eine einfache Formel dafür
eine ganz einfache simple Formel dafür
die erklärt warum
Nationen scheitern oder nicht scheitern
jetzt muss man dazu sagen er redet
eigentlich erst in die von
wirtschaftlichen scheitern weil es gibt
ja wirtschaftlich gescheiterte Nationen
die politisch nicht scheitern Nordkorea
wäre so ein Beispiel ja seit Jahrzehnten
wirtschaftlich gescheiter aber immer
noch irgendwie bestehend aber von
wirtschaftlichen scheitern also was was
führt dazu dass das Wohlstand zum
bröselt oder
Systeme und sagen wir mal so eine
Nordkorea wäre ja auch wirtschaftlich
oder ist ja längst gescheitert und ob er
auch sonst gescheiter genau aber
ja weil sie einfach diese dieses Land
sozusagen noch zwischen sich und den und
bösen Kapitalisten im Süden haben wollen
ja also dieses Land ist eigentlich es
gibt ja dafür so einen alten Witz vom
chinesischen henkerwettstreit ja wo ein
ein wo es um die Frage geht wer die
perfekte Enthauptung hinbekommt und der
erste Henker nimmt also sein scharf
geschmiedetes Schwert schlägt los und
mit einem sauberen schlagtrennter den
Kopf ab und danach ist der zweite
henkrad dran so und jetzt ist natürlich
die Frage wie kann man eine
unüberbietbare Leistung überbieten ja
der holt also aus zum Schlag schlägt und
der Kopf bleibt drauf ja und alle gucken
und denken Sie nicht besonders
beeindruckt und darauf sagt der Henker
zum denen quenten nie kennen sie mal
nordkorea ist so ungefähr in der
Position des zweiten Delinquenten also
der Kopf ist abgetrennt aber noch drauf
genau aber davon darf man mal von
solchen makaberen Vergleich mal
abgesehen also die These in dem Buch ist
wenn man es schafft inklusive
Institutionen aufzubauen das heißt ein
möglichst großen Teil der Bevölkerung
mitzunehmen und ihnen eine Chance zu
geben sich am Wettbewerb zu beteiligen
dann gelingt eine wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung wenn aber wenige Eliten die
Macht in ihren Händen halten und die
Institutionen exklusiv sind ja also
ausschließend dann werden sie für
Veränderungen überhaupt nicht
empfänglich sein weil sie sofort Angst
haben müssen ihre Macht zu verlieren
folglich sind diese Länder Statik
statisch ne die auch sich gegen
zerstörerische disruptionen müssen sie
sich wehren und das ganze System
bietet quasi ein und zerbröselt
irgendwann das ist die These in dem Buch
und das wird über Jahrhunderte und an
allen erdenklichen Staaten demonstriere
Venedig ist umso der Aufstieg und und
viele die Möglichkeit quasi vom kleinen
Handwerker zum Kaufmann zu werden und
irgendwann war das Fell des Bären erlegt
und es gab ein paar reiche
Kaufmannsfamilien und die haben darauf
geachtet dass das auch auf ewig so
bleibt das ist übrigens Venedig
vielleicht können wir es mal ganz kurz
anschieben ist total interessant ne ich
meine Venedig ist heute heute ist der
ist das einfach ja ein Museum im Grunde
ein wunderschönes war aber es ist ein
Museum aber das war ein Mittelalter mal
die reichste Stadt der Welt ne und das
und das hatte was mit mit genau diesen
Dingen zu tun da gab es so so eine erste
primitive Form der Aktiengesellschaft
offenbar ja die die Kommentar sozusagen
und dazu gehört das finde ich total
interessant weil man mal versteht wie
ein wirtschaftlicher Aufstieg sozusagen
dann plötzlich beginnt also die Frage
auch der sozialen Durchlässigkeit ja zu
so einer Gesellschaft gehörten zwei
Partner der eine der in Venedig blieb
und der andere der Freisen ging und der
der dort in Venedig geblieben war das
waren sozusagen die die Leute der
Finanzier im Hintergrund hat den
Löwenanteil dieser Unternehmung
finanziert und der Beitrag des Reisenden
Partners bestand hauptsächlich darum
sozusagen die Fracht zu begleiten und
dafür zu sorgen dass die Ware sicher von
A nach B und irgendwann nach Venedig
kommt ja das heißt junge Leute und das
ist ja das interessante die kein
ausreichendes Vermögen vielleicht auch
Menschen aus armen Familien die konnten
so plötzlich in das Handelsgewerbe
einsteigen und auch unwohl dann selber
wohl haben genau das ist interessant und
und daraus folgen dann Innovationen die
die die die bauen dann selber Zeug und
so weiter es gibt einen anderen
interessante Parallele und die die sag
mal das Wirtschaftswunder das deutsche
Wirtschaftswunder hat natürlich auch
viel deswegen ist diese fleißgeschichte
das kann man so nach meinem dafür halt
nicht einfach so wegwischen weil dieser
deutsche Fleiß sozusagen wenn man was
geschafft hat immer noch mehr schaffen
zu wollen hat natürlich in dieser
Generation unserer Eltern dazu geführt
dass die irgendwann viel Geld gespart
haben und dieses Geld haben sie zur
Seite gelegt und haben es wieder
investiert und aus dieser Investition
ist dann den Zweifel noch mehr Geld
geworden das heißt da ist natürlich mit
diesem enormen Fleisch wirklich etwas
gigantisches gelungen und das sehen wir
ja gerade auch bei den bei den Chinesen
beispielsweise und wenn ich dann höre
zum Beispiel nur noch ein kleines
Beispiel es gibt es gibt so so
Plattformen für Maschinen ja mit denen
man alles mögliche herstellen kann und
da sagen Leute dass sie jetzt beobachten
dass auf diese Plattform werden
gebrauchte Maschinen gehandelt
und ein ganz großer Teil dieser
Maschinen wird mittlerweile von Asiaten
gekauft das heißt die kaufen dort auf
diesem auf dieser Plattform deutsche
Maschinen die wir offensichtlich nicht
mehr so benötigen und verkaufen sie nach
Südostasien vor allen Dingen und dort
werden dann wird neuer Wohlstand mit
diesen Maschinen geschaffen das heißt
auch da siehst es sind so viele kleine
Indikatoren die dir zeigen da passiert
gerade was jetzt würde ich das völlig
unterstreichen in dem Fleiß und ich will
es auch gar keinen Wasser in den Weinen
kippen ich will nur sagen der Fleiß
stellt sich da ein wo sehr viele
Möglichkeiten die haben durch Fleisch
ihre Lebensverhältnisse entscheiden zu
verbessern das spielt natürlich eine
große Rolle und das war in der
Wirtschaftswunderzeit ja so also wie
viele Leute sind in der
Wirtschaftswunderzeit von der
Unterschicht in die Mittelschicht
aufgestiegen ne Ende der 60er Jahre
spricht man von der nivelliert
mittelstandsgesellschaft Deutschland ist
eine Zwiebel geworden die meisten
Menschen sind in der Mitte und das
gibt's natürlich eine ganze Reihe von
Gründen ne warum das so ist und wann das
möglich ist und man kann immer sicher
sein da wo die Chancen Gerechtigkeit am
größten ist ist auch die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass fleißig
einstellt muss ich das hoch und in
versperrten Gesellschaften in dem sich
das nicht lohnt da ist der Fleiß deine
Regelfall eben auch deutlich geringer
ich will nur sagen also der deutsche
Fleiß ich weiß nicht ich glaube nicht
dass es ein gehen dafür gibt der hängt
eben auch zusammen ja mit mit
Möglichkeiten sagen das ist so und ich
habe dieses Buch sehr gerne gelesen als
es damals raus kam vor zehn Jahren weil
es hat mir natürlich auch irgendwie gut
gefallen es fällt so in diese in das
gleiche narrativ ja wie Francis Fukuyama
der eben gesagt hat liberal
demokratische Staaten sind allen anderen
per se überlegen
und das hat dieses Buch ja versucht
eigentlich zu beweisen was ich glaube
Institution gibt es eben ein
autokrativen und den Diktaturen und so
weiter eben gerade nicht
so und jetzt war das so interessant für
mich das Buch dann zehn Jahre später
noch mal zu lesen und da hat man
natürlich so Gedanken im Hinterkopf ne
die eine große Frage ist China richtet
sie ganz große genau aber es gibt die
sich fragen wie den Golfstaaten oder wie
Saudi-Arabien z.B ja die haben alle
keine inklusiven Institutionen haben
aber alle kometenhafte Aufstiege in
dieser Zeit das waren sogar die Nationen
die das größte Wachstum überhaupt hatten
und für die die assimuglow jamesynthese
nicht gilt und das weckt ja den Sinn für
das Nachdenken es war mal ganz kurz
Richard weil du das gerade so schön
beschreibst und vielleicht
interessiert's den ein oder anderen weil
wir ja gerade beschrieben haben am
Beispiel Venedig wie die Mittelalter
aufgestiegen sind und interessant ist zu
hören auch wie sie dann abgestiegen sind
bis sie dann das Museum wurden
irgendwann dass sie heute sozusagen sind
also dieses dieses Modell hat dazu
geführt dass diese uns sehr
unternehmungslustigen jungen Männer die
dann auf Reisen gingen die wurden reich
und irgendwann hatten aber die
etablierten Eliten die hatten keine Lust
mehr ihren Reichtum ihren Erfolg mit
diesen jungen aufstrebenden Männern zu
teilen und 1314 ist dann was sehr
interessantes passiert Venedig
verstaatlicht den Handel ja und erhebt
plötzlich sehr hohe Steuern für die
einzelnen Händler und so weiter und
damit wurde dieser Fernhandel zu einer
Domäne des Adels zu einer Domäne von
wenigen genau Exklusion du schließt die
anderen aus und das war sagen Leute die
sich damit viel besser auskennen als ich
das war der wahre Anfang vom Ende dieses
venezianischen Wohlstands das im Grunde
genau das was du gerade beschrieben hast
also es ist eine Bestätigung für die
erste Moto these an der ja auch eine
Menge dran ist und ich möchte mich
fragst du einfach die Frage was fehlt
dem Buch damit man China oder Saudi
Arabien trotzdem irgendwie erklären kann
das passt ja erstmal nicht ne genau also
es war eine Sache fehlt ein Buch die mir
ganz wichtig ist und die den Kritiker
die dieses Buches ich habe keine
einzigen Kritiker gelesen es gibt ja
Kritiker in dem Buch aber nie einen
Kritiker gelesen der diese Kritik mit
mir teilt ja also wo ich dachte ich kann
noch nicht der Erste sein der auf den
Gedanken gekommen ist das hat jetzt zu
dem Zeitpunkt noch gar nichts mit China
zu tun weil das ja noch eine zweite
spannende Frage also die Frage ist ja
warum entstehen in einigen Ländern
inklusive Institutionen ja die
Wettbewerb ermöglichen
Chancengerechtigkeit
Aufstiegsmöglichkeit möglichst viel
Bevölkerung beteiligen und warum ist das
in anderen Ländern nicht so und wenn ich
das Buch lese dann wird eigentlich immer
erzählt von Dummheit Ignoranz ja Silo
denken ja
Besitzstandswahrung so und ich glaube
das stimmt auch alles aber ist nicht der
einzige Grund
ein Land muss die Chance haben diese
inklusiven Institutionen überhaupt
unabhängig von äußeren Einflüssen
aufzumachen
und das ist der Punkt der in dem Buch zu
kurz kommt wenn man sich jetzt so ein
Land anguckt wie den Kongo oder
wenigeria ja das beide gehören zu den
rohstoffreichsten Ländern der Welt
da gibt es keine inklusiven
Institutionen ja im Kongo gibt es 120
Rebellengruppen und es ist egal wer da
irgendwo in Kinshasa so tut als wenn er
das Land regiert also ist ein Land das
vollkommen von Warlords regiert wird
warum weil es diese ganzen Bodenschätze
gibt weil das Land so reich ist und
diese Warlords Arbeiten sämtlich
natürlich zusammen mit ausländischen
Gruppen andere afrikanische Staaten aber
auch die Europäer und Amerikaner und
wahrscheinlich der Asiaten inzwischen
auch alle haben ihre Finger im Spiel
dieses Land hat überhaupt nicht die
Möglichkeit selbst bestimmt sich zu
entwickeln und Institutionen überhaupt
aufzubauen
denn diese Weisheit dass es auf diese
inklusiven ja einschließen Institutionen
darauf ankommt dass es Wettbewerb
braucht Chancengerechtigkeit also auf
die Idee würden ja viele Diktatoren auch
kommen das kann nicht an jeden vorbei
gegangen sein dass das sehr Wohlstands
während ist und dass das auch Länder
stabilisiert aber viele Länder haben die
Chance überhaupt gar nicht weil sie
Spielbälle der Interessen anderer
mächtig sind und dieser Satz fällt in
einem Buch von 600 Seiten an keiner
Stelle es wird immer so getan als wäre
das so Labor versuchen ja und ich
betrachte das hier so ganz unabhängig
wie so ein physikalisches Experiment und
gucke was muss die richtige Zutat sein
damit dass der versucht
und das ist aber in der Realpolitik eben
ganz ganz selten gegeben wann hatte in
ein Land schon mal die Chance sich von
sich aus optimalst möglich zu entwickeln
in einer globalisierten Welt heute ja
erst recht nicht genau und ich finde
dieser Kritikpunkt der ist zu Unrecht
nieder daran gemacht worden das macht
die Thesen nicht falsch ne aber es
erklärt noch etwas mehr warum in manchen
Ländern ist irgendwie man nie was auf
die Kette gekriegt hat und warum in
anderen Ländern dieser dieser Weg in den
Wohlstand geglückt ist ich meine was ja
total interessant ist und daran erinnern
wir beide uns definitiv ich weiß noch
dieses erinnerst du dich an dem Moment
Richard das war wirklich ein spannender
Punkt in unserer Kindheit und Jugend ich
habe es damals aber nur so gefühlt dass
da gerade etwas wirklich
spektakuläres passiert er erinnerst du
dich als plötzlich die ersten
japanischen Autos da waren ja findest du
dich daran 70er Jahre mit großem Staunen
mit Verwunderung und auch so ein
bisschen was machen die da jetzt aber
auch mit dieser Arroganz na gut also die
die sehen jetzt nicht so richtig funky
aus und so weiter die waren nicht
besonders schön so genau waren
überwiegen Kleinwagen ja Anfang genau ne
und gut ich meine so Ende der 70er Jahre
ist die zeitig ich sag jetzt was wofür
ich Ärger kriegt wo die Autos anfing
nicht mehr schön auszusehen
also ich finde da da kam ja ein paar
Modelle die haben das noch etwas länger
durchgezogen aber eigentlich dein
Traumauto Richert ach ich weiß nicht ich
habe jetzt nicht ich bin ja nicht so ein
riesen Autofan aber wenn ich dann schon
mal so was ich ja schon mal mache
Meilenwerk oder so wie alte Autos
angucke
wofür mein Geschmack waren so die Autos
Anfang der 60er war so für mich so der
gefühlte Zenit na es gibt doch ganz
tolle 50er Jahre Autos da gibt doch
Sportwagen aus dem 30er und die toll
sind es gibt noch ein paar Autos aus den
70ern die toll sind ich finde diese
Maseratis aus dem 60er Jahren
unglaublich schön
jetzt nicht Autos für jedermann auch die
alten Alfa Romeos aber es wird schwer in
den 80er Jahren schöne Autos zu finden
ich bin immer begeistert wenn ich in der
Stockholmer Innenstadt oder auch
irgendwo auf dem Land in Schweden in
Lappland sieht man die manchmal noch so
ganz alte Volvos sehen
wirklich wirklich
der mich viel zu viel Schrauberei der
gar keinen Bock drauf keine Zeit und
dann brauchst Du wieder eigene Garagen
und das ganze Zeug das nervt eigentlich
alles nur aber zurück zum Thema ich
hätte das war spannend weil und das
darauf weist eben nein Ferguson hin
dieser Moment in dem Japan plötzlich auf
dem Plan tritt ja die die Weltbühne
betritt und auch da dieser ungeheure
japanische Fleiß der dazu geführt hat
dass sie plötzlich am Start waren und er
sagt nein Ferguson es gibt sozusagen so
ein paar Apps würde man heute sagen ja
sechs Apps die den Erfolg von modernen
Staaten ausmachen Wettbewerb also
richtig harte Konkurrenz sehen wir
überall unbestritten Wissenschaft also
alle wesentlichen Durchbrüche die 17
Jahrhundert ob in Mathe Astronomie physi
gelangen alle in Westeuropa so dann
Rechtsstaat ja in in der
englischsprachigen Welt hat sich
irgendwann mal so einen optimales
System gesellschaftlicher politischer
übrigens herausgeführt um den
Eigentumsschutz richtig ja das war das
aller aller aller wichtigste weil sonst
kannst du das mit Wettbewerb vergessen
ja also man darf dir deine Sachen nicht
nur nicht kopieren man darf sie auch
nicht klauen ja und man darf Dich auch
nicht umbringen dann bist du weg vom
Markt und so weiter also die Entwicklung
der Rechtsstaatlichkeit folgt dem Gesetz
den den Wettbewerber auf dem Markt zu
schützen genau und das ist auch habe ich
jetzt auch wieder in Moldawien erlebt
wenn du mit mir sehr reichen Menschen
dort sprichst mit dem sogenannten
Oligarchen sprichst sehr interessant die
sagen dir naja eine der Gründe warum wir
haben euer Land nach wie vor unglaublich
schätzen ist genau das Recht
Staatlichkeit bei meinem Land wenn in
Russland bist beispielsweise oder in
China auch da kannst du die nie sicher
sein ob nicht morgen einer um die Ecke
kommt und sagt pass mal auf alles was
Dir gehört habe jetzt mir und zwar
einfach nur weil ich es kann oder weil
du irgendwas gesagt hast was mir nicht
passt deswegen ist auch die
Meinungsfreiheit
ein nach wie vor wo wir so oft darüber
reden völlig unterschätztes gut unserer
Gesellschaften im Grunde die Basis für
alles was uns ausmacht würde ich sagen
so dann führt der App moderne Medizin ne
also alle wesentlichen Durchbrüche
Westeuropa Nordamerika
und diese Arbeitsethik ja die Menschen
im Westen waren die ersten die sozusagen
diese sehr harte Arbeit mit dann höheren
Sparquoten verbunden haben was ich
vorhin sagte und was eben dann siehe
Deutschland dazu geführt hat dass man
dieses dieses gesparte Geld wieder
investiert hat und wieder mehr Wohlstand
gemacht hatte oder gebaut hat und so
weiter und dann kommt Japan und zeigt
das kann man kopieren die haben das
kopiert die haben sich das genau
nochmals los übertreiben
ja genau ja
Schlüssel für China Richard weil du
gerade sagst sozusagen
also Rechtsstaatlichkeit ja nicht in dem
ausmacht nein aber
viele der Prinzipien sind da wir müssen
der Ehrlichkeit halber sagen dass
Ferguson ein siebte eine siebte
killer-app unterschlagen hat nämlich
Ausbeutung der Dritten Welt ist richtig
wie heißt wir brauchen die Rohstoffe wir
hatten nicht genug Arbeit
aber die zweite industrielle Revolution
ne Auto ja was braucht ein Auto ja Räder
und womit was macht man da drum Gummi so
diese Gummi ist sämtlich damals
Kautschuk gewesen der aus Belgien kam
und da wurden noch mal locker ein zwei
Millionen Menschen umgebracht und fast
klar und so weiter und rassistisch
unterdrückt aufs Übelste um diese
Kautschukgewinnung da voranzutreiben
oder die die erste illustrielle
Revolution Baumwolle einfach stand ja am
Anfang Baumwolle gab es in England keine
wächst da ursprünglich nicht kommt das
Indien und dann die gigantischen
Baumwoll fahren in Indien Sklavenarbeit
und so weiter also das sollte man nicht
übersehen ja weil das andere klingt so
etwas zu tun man brauchte dieses siebte
Prinz der Killer App brauchte man und
wenn man sich fragt warum wird heute die
Welt so schwierig weil dieses siebte
Prinzip heute nicht mehr so einfach geht
wie vorher das eine ist es gibt mehr
Konkurrenten ja also wenn man jetzt
Rohstoffe ausbeuten will und mit
irgendwelchen Diktatoren gute Deals
macht und den halbsklaven Arbeit
irgendwie die Sachen aus der Erde holt
mein Lieblingsbeispiel so was man im
Kongo in der Zentralafrikanische
Republik coltanförderung und Kobalt ja
für für unsere Elektroautos
alles alles
nur es ist nicht mehr ein Land der Welt
dass das ausbeutet wie es ursprünglich
mal mit England und der Baum wurde war
und in Belgien mit dem Gummi sondern
jetzt konkurrieren die Mächte um die
noch verbliebenen Rohstoffe in einem
immer härteren Wettbewerb das ist eine
große Veränderung gegenüber früheren
Zeiten und dann will ich noch eine
kleine Anmerkung machen weil dass du
dein Lieblingsthema ist was das
arbeitsautos
ja wollte ich gerade arbeiten
[Musik]
dickes Buch dazu gemacht ich weiß nicht
was das Arbeits etwas entsteht mit der
Leistungsgesellschaft das sind aber zwei
verschiedene Dinge die erste
industrielle Revolution wo man dann die
Kinder in den weisenhäusern ja da in den
Textilfabriken hat arbeiten lassen oder
die Arbeiter so mit Alkohol abgefüllt
hat er dass sie diese gefährliche Arbeit
irgendwie stumpfsinnig gemacht haben war
ja keine Leistungsgesellschaft war auch
kein etwas das war ja nicht der Fleiß
und die Hoffnung was sparen zu können
dass man 80 Stunden lang in der Fabrik
ging um mit 35 tot zu sein
das kam ja erst zu dem Zeitpunkt als man
wirklich sagen kann wenn du mehr
arbeitest dann lohnt sich das für dich
ja und wenn du auch so viel Lohn hast
dass der Lohn zu mir ausreicht als
einfach nur dein Leben zu erhalten oder
deine Arbeitskraft so war das ja so 18
20 18 30 18 40 nee wir reden jetzt über
die zweite Hälfte des 19 Jahrhunderts
und der Mann der auf die Idee gekommen
ist also der eigentliche Erfinder der
Leistungsgesellschaft ja war ein
Sozialist
Robert Owen ja der selber eine
Textilfabrik in Schottland
new lanak völlig neu aufgezogen hat in
dem vorher genau diese Verhältnisse
waren ja weisenhäuser ausgebeutet
Trunkenheit der Arbeiter und so ja der
erstmal Alkoholverbot keine Kinderarbeit
mehr und der ist dann hingegangen und
hat so mit so einer Farbpalette Leistung
versucht zu messen ein hat gesagt wenn
du so und so viel Stückzahlen in der
Zeit und so weiter schaffst na dann
kommst du in orangenen Bereich dann
kriegst du mir Melonen und dann hat er
die Arbeitszeiten gesenkt ja wieder mein
Lieblingsthema die Leute haben weniger
gearbeitet aber sie haben dreimal so
motiviert gearbeitet
und das war eine musterfabrik da kamen
die Leute aus aller Welt doch wurde
russische Zahl hin ja um sich das
anzugucken und sagen wie ist das möglich
dass die Leute so wenig arbeiten und so
einen hohen Produktivität Ausstieg
hatten und das war gedanklich gesehen
wir reden jetzt über die Zeit um 18:20
Uhr rum der Anfang der
Leistungsgesellschaft aber bis die sich
irgendwann mal flächendeckend
ausgebreitet hat er das noch mal 50 60
70 Jahre gedauert und mit dem Gedanken
der Leistungsgesellschaft erfunden von
einem Sozialisten einem radikalreformer
damit beginnt jetzt kommt sozusagen die
sechste Komponente dazu die diese große
Rolle gespielt hat die das
Leistungsprinzip sozusagen so hier und
jetzt kommen wir doch finde ich an einen
total spannenden Punkt ich in meiner
Arbeit du in deiner auch
hundertprozentig
ich habe lange nicht begriffen welches
Thema in dem Zusammenhang alles das
spielt was man unter dem Stichwort Erbe
Erben große Erbschaften sozusagen zu
verbuchen hat fand ich wirklich immer
naja gut also erstens ich bin
kanadischer Mensch ich konnte jedem
alles ja und wenn jemand erbt auch okay
denkt dann auch immer es ist auch eine
Last ja wenn man so viel Kohle
plötzlicher da hat muss man sich
irgendwie drum kümmern und hat dann
andere Sorgen dass ich immer muss Leute
Vertrauen verwalten und alles sind
ständig hinter dir her und alle wollen
nur dein Bestes nehme ich dein Geld ja
und du weißt nicht mehr so genau wer
eigentlich wirklich deine Freunde sind
und ist plötzlich nicht mehr ist und so
weiter das alles gar nicht so einfach
deswegen dachte ich immer naja komm
jetzt hör mal auf mit diesem night
Reflex dieses Erben und dann das zweite
war immer dass ich dachte na ja so wenn
Menschen Erben warum warum soll ich dann
irgendwie als Staat oder auch als als
als Bürger dieses Landes sagen ist doch
völlig ungerecht dass da 400 ja
Milliarden jedes Jahr in Deutschland
Tendenz steigend werden vererbt 400
Milliarden aber nur so auf etwa 10 %
genau ja
ganz ganz kleine Schicht aber diese
Erben Generation die Erben richtig Kohle
und dann war immer sein Widerspruch zur
Leistung so das ist genau der Punkt und
das habe ich ganz lange du sicher sofort
aber ich habe es lange nicht begriffen
und das ist da sozusagen einen
Zusammenhang gibt ja zwischen soziale
auch Durchlässigkeit
Aufstiegsmöglichkeiten und eben diesen
Leistungsprinzip Erben verstopft den
auch
das ist so ja und senkt die Arbeit denkt
die Arbeitsmoral so ich habe diese Frage
oder unser Gedanke den wir gerade
entwickeln wenn man nicht erben könnte
ja wäre ja genui genuin liberal gedacht
zu sagen ja dass sie da spricht der
Leistungsgesellschaft das
Leistungsprinzip ist dem Liberalismus
absolut wichtig und deswegen müsste man
als Liberale eigentlich sagen Erben also
sagen wir mal über so ein paar
Habseligkeiten hinaus dürfte es im
großen Stil dürfte es kein vererben
geben ich habe das mal Christian Lindner
gefragt ja spannend in meiner Sendung 12
Jahre her
und er hat darauf die Antwort gegeben ja
im Grundsatz hätte ich recht ne
widerspricht eigentlich dem Liberalismus
aber einerseits müsste man sich
vorstellen dass natürlich auch jemand
ein Unternehmer ja wenn er wüsste dass
er nichts vererben kann die Frage ist ob
das nicht seinem leistungsethos auch
irgendwie Einheit Gebieten würde
das glaube ich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht
weil der könnte dann das hat er in sich
ja als wäre kein erfolgreicher
Unternehmer und B wird kann er ja eine
Stiftung gründen genau und ihn kommt
sehr wichtig ist
dass das noch Entschuldigung ganz kurz
ein Argument noch dagegen also ihn
persönlich in seinem unternehmerischen
ja in seiner unternehmerischen Energie
ja und in seiner Schaffenskraft den
behindert das doch gar nicht ihn
behindert das doch gar nicht im Zweifel
aber das ist auch mit 50 sagen aber ich
habe jetzt so und so viel Millionen die
kann ich kaum noch ausgeben und so aber
ich denke dass wenn jemand so ist dass
er dieses Unternehmen das meint ja der
würde sich zu Tode langweilen wenn er
mit 50 aufhören würde also der wird das
Weitermachen gründen und der hat ja
bestimmt ist entweder wahnsinnig
tierliebt oder er setzt sich für
Umweltfragen ein genau ja irgendeine
andere Person da kann er natürlich eine
Stiftung gründen so aber das andere
Argument war dass das praktisch nicht
geht
weil wenn man wüsste dass man nicht
vererben könnte dann wird es eine
Million Möglichkeiten geben wie man das
doch macht und da würde der Staat im
Zweifelsfall immer hinterherhinken also
mit rechtzeitig verschenken und
portionieren und Ausland gehen und so
weiter so dass er also sagt selbst wenn
die Idee gut und richtig wäre sie wäre
nicht realisierbar das waren damals
seine Argumente also ich ich weißt du
was mein Thema mit Erben immer war ich
ich habe das dann irgendwann mitgekriegt
ja wie viel wie viel Konfliktpotenzial
auch wie viel Frust wie viel wuter
teilweise bei den Leuten ist ja wie viel
Neid auch so auf diese diese ganzen
reichen Erben ja das war immer so diese
Idee da gibt's so ein paar reiche Säcke
und die schenken sich gegenseitig die
Kohle weiter und ich fand das immer
deswegen schwierig weil ich dachte na ja
also das was da jetzt vererbt wird ist
ja häufig Geld das ist erstmal schon mal
versteuert und zwar auch wahrscheinlich
mehrfach versteuert das heißt warum
solltest du als Staat dann noch mal Geld
abgreifen das ist alles versteuertes
Geld und man könnte auch irgendwie das
Gegenargument aufmachen und sagen das
war fand ich immer sehr plausibel weißt
du wenn Leute sparen und erfolgreich
sparen warum sollte ich sie dafür
bestrafen bin doch einer weiteren Steuer
weil ich ja quasi den belohne der so es
gibt ja die Leute die hauen die Kohle
raus die rauchen und trinken und sie
sind alles völlig wurscht und irgendwann
bist du völlig mit los und dann fällst
du natürlich dieser Gesellschaft der
Krankenkasse in jedem Fall und auch die
Gesundheitswesen fällst du auf jeden
Fall zulasst das heißt du kostest dann
am Ende deines Lebens kostest du
wahrscheinlich die Gesellschaft eine
ziemlich signifikante Summe ja aber wenn
und Leute jetzt nur damit ich nicht im
Staat auf der Tasche liegen ist ja in
Ordnung ist ein anderes als Verben ja
aber ich meine nur daraus kommt ja
erstmal die Tatsache dass da jemand Geld
hat so dann hat er das gespart dann hat
er das alles brav versteuert und hat es
auf die hohe Kante gelegt und dann kommt
der Start und sagt und jetzt vererbst du
und jetzt bitte schön
sind wir direkt wieder am Start und
Sagen hätten wir noch mal gerne 10% von
dir bei großen Unternehmen
Deutschland lebt von diesem Mittelstand
schwieriges Thema wie du weißt natürlich
großer Wohlstand auch in maschinenbeginn
klar so und inwiefern greifst du dann
plötzlich sozusagen genau in diesen in
diese Substanz eines Unternehmens ein ja
indem du das dann plötzlich besteuert
wobei wobei der der Gesetzgeber da auch
schon Unterschiede macht genau also der
der guckt schon in welcher Form ist aber
aber das Thema ja das Thema deswegen
heißt weil du du musst nur diese zwei
Zahlen mal wissen ja
400 Milliarden werden jedes Jahr im
Moment vererbt Tendenz steigend und nur
8 Milliarden Steuern darauf gezahlt 8
Milliarden und da verstehst du sozusagen
woher dann auch diese diese Gelüste
kommt dazu sagen da müssen wir jetzt mal
rein dann gibt es diese diese
Freibeträge ja also du kannst ja an
Eltern kann pro Kind alle zehn Jahre
400.000 Euro verschenken ohne dass es
versteuert wird dass wenn du zwar sehr
wohlhabende Elternteile hast die gleich
nach der Geburt des Kindes mit diesen
Schenkungen beginnen werden bis zum 21
lebensjahr kannst du zweieinhalb
Millionen einfach so steuerfrei
weitergeben die große Frage
gesellschaftlich was macht das du
sagtest gerade das verstopft sozusagen
genau das verstopft so ähnlich aus genau
und Jameson sagen darum geht's inklus
Inklusion ja und das ist jetzt äh nicht
in dem Bereich gemeint dass Menschen mit
Beeinträchtigungen wie in der Schule
sondern Inklusion einfach weil man
möglichst viele müssen eine möglichst
faire Chance haben ja in
rechtsstaatlicher Sicherheit und
entsprechender Förderung und Zugang zum
Bildungssystem und so weiter ihren Weg
zu machen genau so das ist ja im Grunde
genommen die Aussage und das ist richtig
richtig
von der Gegenseite kommt genau ja also
dass das Blut fließt jetzt nicht
schneller durch die Gesellschaft sondern
eher so ein paar Arterien die dadurch
eher verstopft werden
also weil dann der Zugang zu zu
bestimmten Positionen ich meine weil sie
sehen im Augenblick auf eine spannende
Art eine andere Form von Vererbung über
die auch nicht viel geredet wird das ist
wenn Leute die einflussreiche Positionen
haben oder sehr bekannt und berühmt sind
ihre Kinder in Stellung bringen so wie
Heidi Klum zum Beispiel oder die
geilsten ja ungeachtet der Frage ob man
jetzt aus optischen Gründen sagen würde
die kämpfen für diesen Beruf in Frage ja
oder das Unterhaltungs Talent ihrer
Eltern haben die Geissens Kinder auch
nicht aber wie man sozusagen ein
Imperium aufbauen kann und ist das jetzt
nichts gesellschaftlich schlimmes aber
es ist interessant dass man ja auch
Zugang den man sich einmal erarbeitet
hat oder auf dem man gewonnen hat
vorsichtige ausgedrückt dass man den ja
auch weiter ist der Türsteher für seine
Kinder genau
und ich glaube das ganz viele Menschen
und nicht nur die genannten Beispiele
darin auch so ihre Aufgabe sehen ja ja
und und dem Fall von Heidi Klum hat man
aktuell auch nicht viel dabei gerade das
ist mich wundere mich immer ich bin
immer überrascht davon aufs Neue positiv
überrascht was du alles zum mitkriegst
Richard guckst du die Geissens
ich habe tatsächlich schon einige Folgen
der Geissens gesehen ich denke man kann
sagen aus Verzweiflung ja also ich bin
ja ich bin ja altmodisch ne ich gucke
keine Netflix Serien und so weiter also
alles was richtig gut ist entgeht mir
vielleicht könnt ihr ja immer sagen
Streaming Dienste nehme ich nicht wahr
aus ökologischen Gründen ja weil der
Stromverbrauch der damit einhergeht
hundertmal schlimmer ist als alle
Kreuzfahrtschiffe und aller Luftverkehr
der Welt zusammen das ist auch so das
interessant ne ja aber ich habe diese
Entwicklung nicht mitgemacht ich gucke
ja wohl nicht so viel Fernsehen haben
nicht so viel Zeit dazu aber ich bin in
meiner Verzweiflung so nachts im
Hotelzimmer und sowas schon mal hängen
geblieben dass ich dachte die anderen
Programme die laufen sind schlechter
einziger sind
okay das ist tatsächlich so also ein
bisschen Unterhaltungsfaktor habe ich
darin gesehen also diese diese
Nachrichten aus neureichenburg die man
da so aufnimmt die die die das ist so
eine so eine Dimension was ich komme mit
solchen Leuten im Leben sonst nicht
zusammen ne sondern man hat ja nur
Klischees darüber und das dann zu gucken
und zu sieht zu sehen dass man seine
Klischees zurecht hat ja das ist gut ja
es ist ich finde das muss jetzt alles
geben und es ist auch alles völlig in
Ordnung nein aber nochmal zurück zum
Thema das heißt es geht es geht
eigentlich um die Frage des Aufstiegs
und da und da auch da das ist ja
wirklich interessant ich habe jetzt bei
der Krönung von Charles da habe ich
jetzt mal den Fernseher angemacht ja und
war dann irgendwie fasziniert von dieser
von dieser goldenen Kutsche und dachte
oh mein Gott ey und auch die allein die
die den Nackenstarre die sich entwickeln
muss oder so umsonst und auf dem Kopf
tragen muss für so lange Zeit und ich
sehe die da alles so sitzen und ich
musste also spezialisierten
Reihe da saßen fast nur alte Leute es
war sehr interessant
sehr viele Leute die so aussehen als
wären sie auch miteinander in
irgendeiner Form verwandt oder
verschwägert ja das war auch sehr
interessant also ich finde sozusagen
sehr ungünstig gemischt haben
genau und die froh werden um jeden
Tropfen frischen blutest der da mal
reinkommt ja aber das will man nicht
sondern man bleibt selbstverständlich
unter sich ja und ich musste so in
unseren England Film denken unsere
Dreharbeiten die wir da in England vor
ein paar Jahren hatten wo mir klar wurde
was für ein unglaubliches Kastensystem
England ist und die Leute die da
gesessen haben das waren diese paar
Dutzend Leute denen faktisch ganz
England gehört denn gehört das ganze
Land dann gehört das alles das sind
diese Großgrundbesitzer denen wirklich
alles gehört also da müsste assimugalo
sofort gegen Vorgehen ja
und läuft ja auch gerade nicht gut in
England
die die Verstopfung warum Demokratien
können so altern ja das genau diese
Tendenz dass man aber ein Autokratien
zurecht ja verachtet sich schleichend
darin aussieht dann warum genau das ist
noch eine schnelle Frage weil das
interessiert ich habe jetzt ihre Charles
Krönung nicht gesehen mega gibt es
diesen Adelsexperten dessen Name ich mir
nicht merken kann
segelmaschine
habe übrigens ich auch aber hat er das
noch mal kommentiert weil der ist ja
glaube ich schon lange imitiert nee nee
also ja ich wusste gar nicht Experten
irgendwann in Ruhestand gehen das finde
ich ihn Widerspruch in sich weil Könige
machen das im Regelfall auch nicht ich
finde man sollte die auf Lebzeiten wie
so ein Synchronsprecher lassen also wenn
ich mal sowas gesehen habe wie damals
Lady Day und so ne und und und
tonjubiläen und so dann nur wegen dieser
Stimme ja und wenn ich mal irgendwie im
Altersheim liege und ich sollte uralt
werden und ich werde so narkotisiert ja
und Kriege so zu oder wer Terminal
sediert dann möchte ich die Stimme von
wie heißt jemand
im Ohr haben Seelmann also man kann
nicht beruhigender genau ja ins Jenseits
im überfahren ja wie der mit diese
liebevolle Stimme mit der da so eine
Pelzmütze und irgend so ein Orden
beschrieben werden und das mit so einer
gesehen
freundlichen Pilzen ja in der alles
seine Bedeutung hat großartig großartig
das ist eine Gabe ja und ich würde
sofort eine Petition unterschreiben den
Herrn des Namen ich wenn ich merken kann
sofort wieder zurückzuführen Rolf
Seelmann eggeberg
als jedermann eggebert kommen wir zurück
zurück
in Reihe 1 2 und 3 dieser Krönung von
von King Charles für mich ist das immer
noch ein Prinz egal und alle sitzen da
und und Camilla guckt irgendwie und er
selber Charles guckt er auch so ganz
ganz ernsthaft von seiner eigenen
Bedeutsamkeit tief ergriffen das war
sehr interessant das zu sehen hat
irgendwie nie gelacht und dachte Alter
als freudig doch mal heute ist ein
großer Tag für dich ja du bist jetzt
endlich mal König hatte das Gefühl oh ja
ja ja die Last von 2000 Jahren irgendwie
drückt den jetzt irgendwie nieder und
dann kommt noch diese Krone oben drauf
und er war heilfroher das Ding warten
eben konnte aber dahinter diese erste
zweite dritte Reihe da saßen die diese
ganzen Leute denen das ganze Land gehört
und alle alt und alle keinen Bock auch
nur irgendwas davon abzugeben und ich
erinnere mich an diese Geschichte damals
wir haben in England gedreht und ich
habe mit einem mit einem dieser dieser
päch dieser Risiken Landgüter gesprochen
man kommt ja dahin aus unserer Welt und
denkt das ist der Bauer der der die dem
gehören die Kühe und die gehört
natürlich auch das Land aber nichts
gehört da irgendjemandems gehört alles
immer dem Land Lord dem gehört das alles
diesen wahnsinnigen Großgrundbesitzern
und der erzählte mir die schöne
Geschichte wie die sozusagen ihre
eigenen Gesetze machen und den Hals
nicht voll kriegen es gab von der
EU-Förderungen für die einzelnen Tiere
Schafe Kühe und so weiter die haben die
abgegriffen die Bauern zu Recht auch für
ihre harte Arbeit und es passte den aber
nicht diesen landlord sondern wie gesagt
weißt du was dann sorgen wir jetzt dafür
das ist diese Subvention nicht mehr für
die Schafe und die Kühe gibt sondern
gibt's ab sofort pro Hektar das war
nationale Gesetzgebung von der EU
überhaupt nicht so gedacht und
intentiert aber einfach um diese Typen
noch reicher zu machen als sie ohnehin
schon waren und habe ich damals gedacht
sie ist und genau ist das was die Leute
dann triggert und da hebelst du ja auch
das Leistungsprinzip komplett aus ja
für den armen Bauern plötzlich nicht
mehr sich noch mehr anzustrengen und
noch fünf Schafe mehr zu scheren und zu
züchten weil die Kohle dafür greift sich
jeder andere habe ja also es war ja eine
der bergwürdigsten Entscheidung der EU
überhaupt die Subventionen von der Größe
der Betriebe abhängig zu machen je
größer die Betriebe umso mehr
Subventionen kriegen sie also mehr
Ungleichheit in der Landwirtschaft
konnte man übrigens genau wo ich mich
auch frage wie war das überhaupt möglich
genau aber es sind Leute mit Einfluss
und die machen ihre eigenen Gesetze und
ihre eigenen Regeln und das ist
sozusagen das von dem ich glaube da
beginnt der Abstieg von Nationen sie
Venedig und jetzt haben wir ein ganz
anderes Thema als zu sagen in
Deutschland dass der Fleiß nach oder wir
haben Innovationen verschlafen was ja
beides stimmen kann sondern wir können
sagen wenn Systeme Alter und da sind die
parale Demokratie nicht von
ausgeschlossen ja dann dann verstopfen
sie mit der Zeit das heißt das Besitz
standswahrung nimmt zu
Chancengerechtigkeit dem tendenziell ab
und das kann eben auch freiheitlich
liberalen Demokratien passieren also ich
habe mich ja viel mit Bildung
beschäftigt und die besten
bildungsaufstiegsmöglichkeiten in
Deutschland gab es in den 80er Jahren da
war Deutschland führend in Europa und
jetzt sind wir nur noch auf irgend so
einen blöden Mittelplatz
ja weil was ist ja klar was passiert
weil reiche Leute schicken ihre Kinder
auf Privatschulen setzen die von Anfang
an auf ein anderes Gleis damit sie mit
den anderen nicht zu tun haben ich dich
Schulen in sozialen Brennpunkten werden
relativ schlechter im Vergleich zu denen
in den wilden Vororten und so weiter das
Sprengel Prinzip ist ja weitgehend
aufgehoben ne also man kann also
rechtzeitig gucken dass die Kinder mit
Kindern aus schwierigen Elternhäusern
nichts zu tun haben für die ist keine
richtige Lobby da und so weiter und das
heißt also da beginnt natürlich genau
jener Prozess ja der in dem Buch warum
Nationen scheitern als Grund für
scheitern angegeben hat ich denke mir
immer unser Land braucht dringend eine
Blut Auffrischung und nicht nur mein
lieblings Gedanke dazu ist wenn ich kann
ja in meinem Leben nicht alles machen ne
aber wenn ich noch irgendwas also ein
größeres Projekt noch anfangen würde
dann wäre das eine eine Akademie für
hungrige
super ja weil ich damals wohl haben
einen Elternhäusern kommt und so weiter
der hat natürlich Möglichkeiten sehr
gute Schulen zu besuchen wo es mit Noten
nicht schafft gibt es noch eine zweite
Garnitur von welchen immer noch gute
Schulen sind wo man auch ohne
Topleistungen hinkommt aber es gibt so
viele witzige geistreiche hungrige
Menschen die vom Elternhaus her nicht
die Chance gehabt haben überhaupt auf
diese Schiene zu kommen die gibt es aber
hier der Schule und in jeder Klasse die
könnte man identifizieren und den
Stipendien zu geben und sie von den
besten Lehrern ausbilden zu lassen ich
glaube dass das was dabei rauskommt
gigantisch viel besser kreativer
spannender und wichtiger für unsere
Gesellschaft wäre als diese etablierten
und eben auch zunehmend verstopften
Bildungswege
und ich glaube sowas müsste es geben und
zwar in großer Zahl das spannend wir
haben ja noch keine Antwort darauf
gefunden warum China ein Aufstieg
geglückt ist
obwohl sie keine inklusiven
Institutionen haben obwohl es da keine
Presse und Meinungsfreiheit gibt obwohl
die Partei da überall exklusiv ja den
Daumen drauf hat vielleicht könnte auch
neben vielen anderen ein Aspekt sein
dass man ziemlich vielen Leuten die
Chance gegeben hat aufzusteigen
ja das macht aus China keine liberale
Demokratie aber es wäre eine unter
mehreren Erklärungen warum das Land
jetzt wohlstandsmäßig so durch die Decke
gegangen ist gegenüber dem elenden
Zustand in die mau China vorgefunden und
übergeben richtig richtig also Richard
spannend wir sollten investieren in
Schulen in Aufstiegsmöglichkeiten und
sollten vor allen Dingen uns nächste
Woche wieder treffen zu einem weiteren
Austausch dass er den großen Spaß
gemacht hat tschüss
[Musik]
2 und Pots bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF